in true soulslike fashion Lords of the
Fallen takes place in a dark fantasy
world brimming with magic gods and
demons in more instead the fires of the
Demon Lord adier battle against the
radiant light of the judge cleric and
orius all while the hungering umbrell
stalks everyone from behind the scenes
for each of these factions the game
offers a different conclusion there are
three endings radiant infernal and
umbrell and in this video I'm going to
explain each one if you like this type
of content feel free to subscribe to the
channel since I do a lot of it here and
most of you watching probably aren't
subbed with that I'm mad Luigi and I
hope you enjoy the
show the first ending most players will
get is the standard light or radiant
ending this requires that you do as you
are told and cleanse the five beacons
the other endings require more NPC
quests and additional steps and lots of
the NPCs are really easy to miss in this
game yeah the SS like all right so
chances are radiant is most players
first ending this ending follows the
game's most straightforward path of
beating the corrupted Sentinels guarding
each Beacon of light these are the main
bosses and then cleansing the beacons
these pillars are meant to safeguard
against a deer's return a deer is a dark
lord responsible for the rogar all the
fire enemies and demons we fight
throughout the game at one point a deer
ruled the world but he was overthrown
and cast into another realm this all
happened at least a millennial ago and
humankind has been governing itself
somewhat autonomously ever since as the
opening cinematic shows the beacons have
been corrupted and a deer is poised to
make a return in response we are charged
with stopping this from happening and
that's exactly what we do in the radiant
Ending by cleansing the five beacons we
act in direct opposition to the forces
of a deer this leads us to battle his
rogar army in addition to his followers
such as Damar Rose The Marked who
becomes a boss fight in this route we
must also fight the five corrupted
Sentinels who stand seemingly to protect
the beacons you would think they would
be happy to have us show up to do some
cleansing but since they are corrupted
either by umbrell happenings a deer's
influence some other zombification or a
mix of all the above they all choose to
fight us and speaking of a deer's
influence it seems that the recent surge
in rogar and the corruption taking place
throughout the world is thanks to the
Rune of a deer if we follow the quest of
the iron wayf farer he reveals that he
had the Rune of a deer before handing it
over to the judge cleric to deal with he
wasn't a man of faith and felt that if
anyone was qualified to deal with the
Rune it was the judge seems like he also
didn't want it to be his problem anymore
but he laments that this doomed morstead
for generations and led to the state we
see it in now the judge was either
unable or unwilling to destroy or
properly seal the Rune and it corrupted
her in the whole Kingdom the item itself
comes into play again in the other
endings but this ending doesn't make use
of it beyond having it be the Catalyst
of the current apocalypse so we continue
through the game as normal until we come
to face a deer at its end we find an
imprint of melor that shows us he was
used by the rogar to serve as some kind
of vessel or conduit for a deer who we
can talk to a deer offers us a choice
freedom and what he calls the truth he
points out the hypocrisy of the radiant
followers who decry the umbrell but also
make use of its power and employ you as
their Champion someone who makes use of
umbrell through our lamp but this is the
radiant ending so we enter the rogar
realm to deal with the deer once and for
all the boss fight is Stark in design
but unfortunately it's a bit boring
since you just hunt down zombie mobs
marked by a deer eventually taking out
the whole level honestly the focused
room and Hell setting made it kind of
feel like a doom level to me and I can
imagine having some waves of enemies
would have been fun where you can use
the terrain to separate and deal with
them so it's not just like a spam
manfest but we unfortunately did not get
that just zombies so that we can focus
on a deer speech which is a warranted
design Choice having a mechanically
simple level so you can focus on the
narrative aspect of a deer the spectacle
the speech but I do think it could have
been a better experience if there was
some mechanical payoff in addition to
the narrative payoff so in this speech
adir reveals a lot about himself and the
lore of the world he claims to have
created and ruled over mankind as a
benevolent Shepherd leading with wisdom
and love and for that he was repaid with
betrayal the judges launched a crusade
against him despite his creation of the
rogar armies he was beat unable to be
killed by them the judges exiled ad deer
to this prison Dimension where he has
remained ever since he mocks how the
judges soon themselves became revered as
demigods and how Humanity fell
into hatred suffering chaos Adar thinks
this proves Humanity needs his guidance
and he points out how the other Godlike
beings of the world orius the leader of
Radiance and the creature of the umbrell
both Hide Away whereas he is open and in
front with us and we can see him as he
nears his death he gets more controlling
claiming his godhood and Creator status
deem him worthy of leading that we have
no right to go against him and destroy
him in this way in the end the umbrell
lamp is able to vaporize and absorb a
deer as the end title notes it knows no
satiation this also confirms that a deer
is in fact a God so he was being
truthful on that account they go on to
say how we or's champion and wibr are
rewarded for our actions we are
annihilated possibly from the explosion
from a deer or from orus viewing us as
heresy tainted from our use of the um
lamp that would confirm some hypocrisy
from the radiant Camp after that orius
unleashes his Radiance on Axiom with new
power purifying any who transgress his
will in light they fall and we see this
in action in the credit scene it
basically looks like morstead is just
getting glassed by tactical nukes of
Radiance light there are a lot of beams
and basically everyone has transgressed
upon some part of radiant law at this
point the judge cleric herself looks
like this after all so I don't know if
anyone will be left after all this
cleansing and we never see orus directly
unlike a deer and the umbrell entity
known as the putur mother who we see in
the umbrell en
but this end card and the magic of
Radiance seem to confirm him as a real
entity but he is too holy to actually
show himself in the events of the game
like a deer says and we aren't around to
see him afterwards since we get atomized
too in judging this ending we should
remember that oris's followers turned
out to be pretty bad leaders of mankind
engaging in torture and butchering the
people of morstead feta is pretty cool
after being reborn and she vouched for
the average Joe in life but she was told
to can by the judge cleric's abses and
maybe we can say a lot of that was
corruption from the ruin of a deer but
even without that it seems that there
was a lot of deification of the judge
cleric and the religious order that
could have easily led to similar
corruption or abuse of power so with all
that and orus going pretty Ham on the
planet right now the new world is
probably in for a rough time of
religious persecution and domination
once again this ending is the most
normal in the sense that it retains some
humankind centered order
but Ora seems pretty deceptively
dangerous or he just really lets his
followers get swayed by evil influences
maybe that's okay now that a deer is no
more but the umbrell is still around
between that and all the cleansing this
ending is definitely an uneasy one at
Best But now let's look at the others to
see how this One
Compares on the flip side of the radiant
is a deer's ending you can achieve this
one relatively simply as well but it
does allow for a few extra steps first
we can do Damar Rose's quest line in
this ending since she is a follower of a
deer our interests align this time
around that's thanks to the fact that in
game we aren't going to be cleansing any
of the beacons instead we just beat each
boss and then leave the beacon alone
they have been corrupted by a deer
already so they're working to bring him
back to this realm we don't want to get
in the way of that for his ending so we
play through beat the bosses grab the
Rune and make it to a deer once more but
this time we are on his side so instead
of lecturing us he takes his Rune and
empowers it and he tells us what to do
next use the Rune to Snuff out each
Beacon and confront the traitor which is
elel the original name of the judge
cleric at each Beacon there is now a new
contingent of enemies guarding them but
we beat the Sentinels so some fodder
bosses aren't going to stop us
especially when we can just run past
them and interact with the beacon we
snuff out each one and then bring the
Rune to the defeated judge cleric for
context the remembrance of the judge
cleric the radiant Sentinel reveals her
back story it tells us that she was once
a warrior Priestess of a deer named Isel
one day she decided she had been living
a lie and turned against a deer swearing
to end his rule or die obviously she was
successful in this as a deer Was
Defeated and imprisoned since then she
has lived as the judge cleric leading
Humanity maybe a time before this recent
corruption wasn't so bad with her in
charge before she was corrupted by the
Rune and became an incarnate of that
very same thing she once rose up against
it's possible that before the run's
influence the world was decent some of
the in-game characters do seem to Fancy
the past a bit unfortunately we can't be
certain or confirm this so we take the
Rune to Iselle and enter her mind with
it we are transported to a lush
Mountaintop aelle is calm calls us over
and offers Little Resistance I don't
think a deer is influencing her here
maybe she just knows she has no way of
resisting but who knows this imagined
world is much more peaceful than the
real world of darkness and fire that
actually exists outside around the judge
perhaps she can't bear to see what she
has become and uses this to cope kind of
like the facade we see crumble away
after her first phase in the boss fight
we hold the Rune up to her and she seems
to gladly accept it maybe this is
actually some part of a deer that has
been trapped within Iselle all this time
the room glow and we eventually wake up
in the real world a deer has taken the
body or form of zel and tells us to rise
as his Rogue our Lord we are kneeling
and service to our new king and God the
end notes tell that the Exile ader is
back in the form of Isel the one who
imprisoned him because of the treachery
of aelle his second Reign is informed by
a rage of betrayal to me this clearly
reads like he is going to be doing some
glassing and cleansing of his own with
all his Hellfire the cards also call us
his infernal Champion but that we are
only the first of his new rogar Lords
this could be setting up some DLC bosses
as a set of rogar Lords would be a
pretty sensible choice for a gamut of
new bosses but in world this signals
more a deer destruction and control the
rogar are pretty liberal with attacking
and killing and a deer is angry so he's
going to be letting them run loose on
all those who stand against him and
anyone even distantly related it's hard
to trust a deer when he talks about how
peaceful and loving he was as a ruler
after all the theme of crimson and
possibly fire was present in his past
age as was the existence of War priests
as confirmed by the judge cleric
remembrance so there was some Waring and
fighting happening and his warriors were
to some degree associated with his
religion and worship that's a lot of
connection to what he currently looks
like I would assume this demon Fire Lord
was always pretty close to his current
self and his appetite for Revenge now
that he's back in control spells a bad
time for anyone still remaining in
morstead or probably the rest of the
world so it's hard to say that the first
ending was good but this one almost
definitely is not with that we have seen
the endings of orius and a deer now
let's look at the final primordial being
the putrid mother and its ending of
umbrell the umbrell ending is the most
involved and distinct among the three it
consists in many steps unrelated to the
beacons dealing with NPCs new items and
new areas and it all starts in the very
bottom of the map beneath the mines we
come across hero or dervla and the putur
child Peta gives us some information
about this kid noting that it's
regrettable to have to lock up a kid but
it must be done to maintain stability
against umbrell without such a bull
workk the umbrell dimension might be
able to encroach on Axiom beginning its
consumption or invasion of the Overworld
Tia notes that there can be value in
suffering which is true but it's a small
justification for the lifetime
imprisonment of a child after finding
this area we can purchase the scouring
Clump from Mulo this lets us enter the
mother's LOL in the arena once we access
the umbrell dimension here we can
properly start the end's Quest this
mainly consists in getting seed pods
from umbrell for specific people going
to those NPCs and then using the seed
pod to absorb their soul or Essence
these seed pods note that umbrell is
inherently inimical or hostile to the
very nature of anyone who steps inside
this gives us a small insight into the
blue Dimension that it is by nature
opposed to or parasitic to every living
thing in Axiom or in general so next up
we seed pod ginda and Damar Ro removing
them from the world then we kill the
light Reaper to reveal an umbral
parasite that Malu feels like a failure
for having lost control over it's
unclear how the umbrell got infested
into the rogar that a deer specially
made but it makes some sense since it
was the one rogar in charge of hunting
down lamp bearers Those Who Bore an
umbra lamp so there is a connection
there and and mohu also gives hints
towards the ending saying how umbrell
will soon Blom upon this base reality
after the light Reaper we turn to
umbrell and fully commit to the path the
Rune of a deer turns withered it now
reveals what anyone with umbrell
knowledge apparently knows that the
puted mother is always watching like
some kind of love crafty and horror then
we have another Gauntlet of seed pods to
use first we confront a deer who is
using Mel's body as a conduit he says he
feels sorry for us that we were LED
astray by a monster who will consume us
as a last ditch Temptation he offers us
the world in classic fashion of a
mephistophelian devil but here we are
followers of the mother so we suck him
up too next on the list is Harkin also
known as the iron wayfairer Harkin is
the name of the protagonist of the first
Lords of the Fallen from 2014 in the
original he was covered in runes and
when we see the Wayfair his face we can
see he also has the same runes plus he
is likely who is referenced in Sparky's
dialogue here another like you Rome's
mste traveler a man I encountered long
ago one already burden then a burden
which has only increased enormously in
the years since and taken a heavy toe
and his is a bleak ruinous road with
that and knowing that this game
technically takes place in the same
universe as the first game just
thousands of years in the future it's
safe to say that these are the same
person Parkins parasite describes how he
has done great good and appalling evil
and the dark actions he took seem to
have finally consumed him in his quest
line we see him give in to despair
wanting to burn morstead and all the
people in it but we obviously aren't
going along with that so we defeat him
in combat and here at the end beaten and
defeated he accepts his story's
conclusion at our hands through the
withered Rune of a deer finally we find
the last parasite in our very own Peta
we learn that mhu tried many times to
imbue a mother and her baby with the
umbrell obviously killing all the failed
attempts he succeeded in Peta and killed
her mother since she was of no more use
for him this lines up with how we see
Peta eventually ending up in the
orphanage so we Soul Peta and fight
alanne the starved after killing The
umbrell Entity her remembrance reveals
that Peta acted against the parasites
influence when she acted in service of
some bigger purpose like her religion
and when she gave life to others I think
this reveals that the true nature of
umbrell is malignant and parasitic it is
a negative life sapping force with this
final parasite we can achieve the ending
returning to the umbrell dimension we
can directly interact with the PED
mother she offers no words she just
sucks us up but for umbrell Fanatics
this seems to be be the goal Malu
desperately desired to be reunited with
the mother and the ending title card
characterizes our absorption as
something positive we enter her maternal
Embrace after proving our devotion to
her we learn that what Peta feared takes
place the barrier against umbrell breaks
down and the blue mukbang dimension
encroaches on all other creation nothing
will be spared all will be consumed the
mother seems to be almost a force of
nature something which must feed on
anything and everything it possibly can
all creation will now be consumed by
this umbrell matriarch our path rejected
the radiance of orius and the fires of a
deer choosing instead to absorb the
latter to serve the prime umbrell entity
in this end we help this force of nature
achieve its desire in doing so we doomed
the world to be consumed by her it
sounds to me like everything becomes one
in the fured mother that's the only
logical conclusion to her feeding on
everything this is kind of like Elden
Ring's frenzied flame ending where all
is burned to become a singular one great
everything in morstead and Axiom and
every other land is absorbed into the
mother here it all becomes one in her in
judgment I would say an end to all
existence via the puted mother's plate
seems like a pretty hopeless conclusion
which is about power for the course when
we see the effect umbrell has on those
who are exposed to it other than us I
guess tangle of wet meat is undone by
her Majestic
Beauty with the three achievement
earning endings of Lords of the Fallen
explained we should now have a clearer
picture about what each one entails
honestly none of them seem to be very
good the only one our character even
survives is one where we become a
lieutenant to the devil in contrast
Elden Ring's endings seem positively
hope which is really saying something
given how overall depressing those
endings really are so those are the
conclusions to the story of Lords of the
Fallen I hope you've enjoyed watching
this video if you have feel free to
subscribe to the channel or support me
on patreon thanks to my patrons who do
support and thank you for watching I'm
mad Luigi and I'll see you in the next
video peace